spring cleaning season is upon us
everybody yes i'm sorry to break it to
you and a great way to kick off things
or complete the job is getting your
carpet cleaned by the best in the bays
xero rez of course welcome back guys hey
good to see you good to see you too now
we know xero rez is a family business
you guys are keeping other families
homes clean though so what what do you
guys do for the community you know what
we do is we want vegas to be the
cleanest healthiest place there is oh
yeah especially with the wind we've been
having this week it is time to get your
carpets clean take care of that spring
cleaning and we do it with this
revolutionary zr water technology
there's no soaps no harsh chemicals just
clean carpets that you'll love and is
that what makes xerorez unique you know
in comparison to other
absolutely carpet cleaning's been going
on the same for about 80 years
they take soap they put in your carpet
and they attempt to get it out
leaving a ton of residue behind that's
why your carpets get crunchy and they're
all stinky and nasty after a carpet
cleaning you don't have that problem
with zebra res okay and speaking of all
that let's get into the demonstration
because we have that nasty crunchy
carpet right here absolutely so tell us
how the machines and the technology work
so we've got this
this is our it's got a vacuum on here
plus our water our special alkaline
water that we clean with and there's no
soaps there's no harsh chemicals you can
see right away
the night and day difference
and it's hooked up to like a 300
horsepower vacuum so we suck up all that
dirt and nastiness back to the truck
right you don't have to worry about it
ever again man you can see that look at
that i would feel comfortable in jelly
beans earlier in the show if a jelly
bean fell i could you could eat off
of that the best part rocky is it dries
super fast we're talking a few hours
you'll be have your home back to normal
uh whether it's your home or your
business we can get you taken care of
okay good to know and it's not about
just what you see it's also what's in
the air too with the things you can't
see are really the problems it is yeah
your carpet is actually the largest air
filter at your home or business
and there's been a study that shows that
you can actually reduce the airborne
contaminants by up to 52
in your home or your facility just by
getting your carpets professionally
cleaned and right now that is
really important with all these
allergies oh it is it's crazy i've been
struggling this week i know me too my
eyes are watering i feel you um okay so
how can people get in touch with you
guys and what do you guys are there any
special offers there is give us a call
visit us online at zerorez las vegas dot
com uh our phone number is
702-840-3333 and we've got an amazing
deal our spring cleaning specialist
carpet cleaning as low as 35 dollars per
room plus we'll throw in a free hundred
square feet of tile and grout cleaning
at no charge there's some minimums that
apply but give us a call okay thank you
we appreciate you guys all right let's
go
to the there it is zero spring cleaning
special carpets clean for as low as just
35 per room that is a great offer plus
receive free tile cleaning of 100 square
feet 702
840-3333 or zerorez las vegas dot com
minimums to apply by the way all right
we'll be back on las vegas now
[Music]